hello this is greg DS from the Fuqua
School of Business at Duke University
reporting from Davos 2010 I think the
most exciting development of the next
decade is going to be the inclusion of
social entrepreneurs and solving many of
the world's social problems up to this
point I think there's been a heavy
reliance on top-down solutions the
belief that large-scale institutions and
governments can solve these problems
with large plans we realize now that
there's a lot of uncertainty about
what's going to work and about what will
will solve the problems and about the
kinds of business models and approaches
we need social entrepreneurs have been
out there working at the grassroots
levels developing innovative approaches
to do this many of them have had
tremendous success and I think you need
to learn from what they've accomplished
and continue to learn from what they've
accomplished and we have many of them
here at Davos this year and there we are
all learning from them and I think we'll
continue to learn from them the exciting
thing is I think they're going to become
a regular part of the conversation to me
that's going to take us a leap forward
and I am excited to see that thank you